good morning it's tuesday i've been
thinking a lot about how our information
feeds shape our understanding of the
world
like one of my new favorite youtube
channels curious tangents has a great
video about how people
actually change their minds which is
very different from how i
thought persuasion worked so humans tend
to trust information
that comes from people we trust which is
why so many of our sentences begin
somebody once told me or i heard or my
friend said or whatever but online this
rumor and anecdote driven approach to
information sorting
really runs wild like i've been
repeatedly tagged in this viral tick
talk about a time traveler named noah
who is visiting us from 2030.
this video has over 2 million likes and
because it is such an obvious and
naked example of misinformation i
thought it would be interesting to
analyze it a bit the video begins this
true story about a boy who claims he is
a time traveler will freak you out
okay so no proof is presented here but
critically the video establishes at the
outset what it is going to accomplish
you are going to get
freaked out and we know that humans tend
to pay more attention to information
that is novel or strange or outrageous
in short we look for information that
will freak us out so this is already
very promising
but the real crazy thing about this is
it's not just that he told the future
but as he made all of his claims he
passed a lie detective test not failing
once
okay so there's the proof that noah is a
time traveler from the year 2030 who
came back to tell us about the future
except that one polygraph tests are not
that reliable and two
no evidence is actually offered that
noah took a polygraph test
or indeed that noah exists but now
having offered some semblance of proof
it's time for some claims about the
future
one of the first things noah stated was
that donald trump will be re-elected in
2020 yeah so remember
we look for information that freaks us
out also many social media algorithms
value engagement over accuracy so
predictions that will lead to lots of
engagement are often more successful
than
well-informed predictions you see this
offline too like in sports talk radio
for instance
noah says that humans will make it to
mars by the year 2028
spacex is actually sending their first
ship to mars in 2022.
yeah no spacex is not sending a ship to
mars in 2022 but if you're crafting a
persuasive argument about the future it
makes sense to put something in the
middle about how this is already
happening or we're already starting to
see it because that makes this future
feel graspable
he then states that we will have implant
chips put into our bodies that will
benefit you right then you end with
another prediction that will receive
lots of engagement you don't need to be
from the future to predict microchips in
humans it was predicted almost 20 years
ago in mt anderson's novel feed which
begins with the wondrous first sentence
we went to the moon to have fun but the
moon turned out to completely suck okay
so you would maybe expect the most
popular comments on this video to be
like this is fun and silly and
a little bit creepy or something like
that but no the most popular comments
are either about how chip implants are
the mark of the beast and a sign of the
apocalypse or else they're about donald
trump
because even though the video is clearly
false and doesn't even really try hard
to pretend
otherwise it leads to us feeling real
emotion
fear and outrage and fascination and
that makes us
engage so the video gets shown to more
and more people until eventually it
begins to look
vaguely legitimate because it has 12
million views and comes from a verified
user
this phenomenon where false or
inadequately contextualized information
leads to very real
emotional experiences is for me at least
quite common
and it's powerful i mean even though i
know that video is fake in the future
when i think about chip implants or mars
or trump or whatever
noah's predictions will be somewhere in
my mindscape
literally changing my mind and in that
sense
noah is real whether he exists or not
in fact if a time traveler really came
back from the year 2030 one of the first
things i'd want to know is how we fix
the misinformation problem
the second thing i want to know is how
many titles liverpool wins in the next
decade
again hank i really recommend the
channel curious tangents i think it only
has 8 000 subscribers and it's
great check it out link in the
doobly-doo i will see you on friday